Okay.
Yesterday was the first part of the first
2020 Democratic presidential debate.
It was very interesting.
There are winners and losers, several cringe
moments which we'll talk about.
I live streamed it on our youtube channel
last night.
We'll be live streaming again tonight for
part two assuming that our live streaming
privileges are not taken away, which is happening
to some youtubers who streamed yesterday's
debate.
Not going to get into that now.
Uh, but to reset, Elizabeth Warren was the
only front runner in the first night.
The other is Biden.
Bernie booted, Judge Harris all in tonight's
second part along with Andrew Yang, which
will be interesting.
Now unfortunately a not super surprisingly,
a lot of questions simply weren't answered.
Some weren't answered in particularly pandering
ways, which I'll talk about, but overall there
were some winners in this debate, but it was
not a good debate in the sense that in terms
of this course in depth, it was a disaster.
Part of this is just the number of candidates
on stage.
Part of this is the format because of the
number of candidates on stage.
A answers were one minute and rebuttals.
We're 30 seconds.
Not Everybody got to answer every question.
Not everybody got to rebut every answer.
And my impression overall is that the three
people who did the best were uh, Elizabeth
Warren, Bill de Blasio, and Julio and Castro
who I would say won the debate in terms of
substance and style.
Uh, now that doesn't mean I agree with all
of their positions.
This is not me saying I'm endorsing them.
This is simply evaluating only their performance.
In yesterday's debate.
Of course, Bill de Blasio has no chance of
being the nominee and Julio on Castro has
almost no chance of being the nominee.
Warren polling at about 13% heading into the
debate, uh, one because she said the right
things and she said them in the right way,
period.
She got good questions also that lined up
with her issues and answered the questions
really well.
Here's one example,
but this comes at a time when 71% of Americans
say the economy is doing well, including 60%
of Democrats.
What do you say to those who worry?
This kind of significant change could be risky
to the economy.
So I think of it this way.
Who is this economy really working for?
It's doing great for thinner and thinner,
sliced at the top.
It's doing great for giant drug companies.
It's just not doing great for people who are
trying to get a prescription filled.
It's still a great for people who want to
invest in private prisons, just not for the
African Americans and Latin x whose families
were torn apart, whose lives are destroyed
and whose communities are ruined.
It's doing great for giant oil companies that
want to drill everywhere, just not for the
rest of us who are watching climate change.
Bear down upon us.
When you've got a government, when you've
got an autonomy that does great for those
with money and isn't doing great for everyone
else, that is corruption, pure and simple.
We need to call it out.
We need to attack it head on, and we need
to make structural change in our government,
in our economy, and in our country
all the time.
So there's actually relatively little to talk
about with Warren in that she overperformed
compared to some path debates.
She got good questions that were in her wheelhouse,
just did a good job overall and we'll see
how her polling reacts.
Build the Blasio basically polling seer zero.
The mayor of New York City has no chance,
but he actually did well in this debate because
some of the people on the stage wanted to
sort of play coy with, are you in favor of
this or not?
Or trying to have their cake and eat it too
in the sense of claiming to be progressive
without actually having to say, yes, we need
free college.
Yes, we need medicare for all.
And Bill de Blasio was aggressive in a respectful
way and he had some great moments.
Here's just one example of that.
Well, let me tell you what we're hearing here
already in the first round of questions is
that battle for the heart and soul of our
party.
I want to make it clear, this is supposed
to be the party of working people.
Yes, we're supposed to be for 70% tax rate
on the wealthy.
Yes, we're supposed to be for Free College
Free Public College for our young people.
We are supposed to break up big corporations
when they're not serving our democracy.
This Democratic Party has to be strong and
bold and progressive and in New York we proven
that we can do something very different.
We can put money back in the hands of working
people and let me tell you, every time you
talk about investing in people, in their communities,
you hear folks say there's not enough money.
What I say to them every single time is there's
plenty of money in this world.
There's plenty of money in this country.
It's just in the wrong hands.
Common Democrats have to say
exactly,
this is not a deblazio endorsement.
It's recognizing that he did well for the
format and for this debate, even though he's
still going to be polling very little.
His performance was the second best for me
and then in third place it was Julio on Castro.
He was helped a lot by the immigration crisis
at the border because it pushed the topic
into the debate in a serious way.
He genuinely knows a lot about this issue.
He was able to talk about it in depth with
Cory booker with Beto or Rourke and appear
really strong because he is strong on this
issue.
Let's take a look at one clip.
Thank you very much.
A plus say, I'm very proud that in April I
became the first candidate to put forward
a comprehensive immigration plan and we saw
those images.
Seeing that image of, of Oh, Scott and his
daughter by Lydia, uh, is heartbreaking.
It should also piss us all off.
If I were president today [inaudible]
if I were president today, I would sign an
executive order that would get rid of Trump's
zero tolerance policy, the remain in Mexico
policy and the metering policy.
This metering policy is basically what prompted
or Scott and Valeria to make that risky swim
across the wet river.
They had been playing games with people who
are coming and trying to seek asylum at our
ports of entry or Scott and [inaudible] went
to a port of entry and then they were denied
the ability to make an asylum claim.
So they got frustrated and they tried to cross
the river and they died because of that.
On Day one, day one, I would do that executive
order that would address metering and then
I would follow that up in my first hundred
days with immigration reform that were auto
silent claims that would put undocumented
undocumented immigrants as long as they haven't
committed a serious crime on a pathway to
citizenship.
And then we'd go to the root cause of the
issue, which is we need a Marshall Plan for
on duty
and what the Mandala and in Salvador so that
people can find safety and opportunity at
home instead of coming to the United States
to seek it.
And then later on the same issue going back
and forth with Beto O'Rourke, who was saying
a lot, but making very few points.
Take a look at this
free dreamers forever from any fear of deportation
by making them US citizens here in this county.
Three
in solutions in Central America, work with
regional stakeholders, so there's no reason
to make that 2000 mile journey to this class.
I'll give you 30 seconds.
Very clear.
The reason that they're separating these little
children from their families is that they're
using section 1325 of that act, which criminalizes
coming across the border to incarcerate the
pre the parents and then separate them.
Some of us on this stage have called to end
that section to terminate it.
Some like congressman O'Rourke have not and
I want to challenge all of them.
The candidates don't do that.
I just think it's a mistake.
Bethel.
I think it's a mistake and I think that
that if you truly want to change the system,
then we got to repeal that section, not thank
you.
Then it might as well say the same policy.
Let me respond to this very briefly.
She's a member of Congress.
I helped to introduce legislation that would
ensure that we don't criminalize those who
are seeking asylum and refugee in this country.
If you're fleeing, if you're the one in the
desperation that I want to make sure [inaudible]
with respect, I'm still talking about everybody
else, but you're looking at just one small
part of this.
I'm talking about a comprehensive rewrite
of our immigration laws and if we do that
[inaudible] talking about our laws, I'm talking
about the millions of folks.
A lot of folks that are coming are not seeking
asylum and a lot of them are undocumented
immigrants.
Right.
And you said recently that the reason you
didn't want to repeal section 1325 well it's
because you were concerned about human trafficking
and drug trafficking.
But let me tell you what section 18 is that
got title 18 of the US code title 21 and title
22 already covered [inaudible]
that they were before.
Did your homework [inaudible]
again, if immigration ended up not being a
part of yesterday's debate, Castro probably
bombs in as a non factor, but he did really
well because he's super strong on this issue.
And really other's knowledge of the issue
visibly paled in comparison to Julio on Castro's.
Elizabeth Warren's worst moment was on guns,
just sort of bumbling and mumbling without
really saying very much and repeating that
we should do research.
A couple of times.
Tulsi Gabbert had one good answer at the end
about getting out of Afghanistan.
Otherwise not much of a factor.
She really benefited from Tim Ryan just saying
bone headedly dumb things about nine 11 and
foreign policy, which let Gabbert come in
and make him look very stupid on that issue.
And as far as the attacks that we saw between
candidates other than Julio on Castro going
after Bedo for his position on immigration,
almost every attack was from bill de Blasio.
De Blasio went right after everyone saying,
hey, let's just say we're for progressive
ideas.
If we actually claim to be progressive, the
Blasio with a really great call out of Beto
or Rourke at one point, uh, de Blasio, um,
talking about immigrants didn't do this to
you, huge corporations did, which was a very
good moment for de Blasio.
De Blasio was specific on when we should or
shouldn't intervene in other countries and
the importance of actually having authorized
war powers for a president making those decisions.
Some of the disagreements were, you know,
club Achaar is less into free college than
Warren, at least not in as wide ranging of
a way.
The disagreement I already told you about
between Castro and Bedo and Castro and Corey
Booker on some immigration specifics.
Interestingly on healthcare only Elizabeth
Warren and billed the Blasio raise their hands
when asked, do you want to replace private
health care with a government run program?
This was a crazy moment because it made no
sense that of all the people on the stage,
only Warren and deblazio raised their hands
in this moment I'm going to play, but it also
was a terribly asked question which should
have been called out.
Take a look.
We're going to turn to the issue of healthcare
right now and really try to understand where
there may or may not be daylight between new
many people watching at home have health insurance
coverage through their employer.
Who here would abolish their private health
insurance in favor of a government run plan
just to show hands start out with.
Okay.
Alright.
Well so
only Bill De Blasio and Warren put their hands
up.
This is a concern.
I mean there should be other hands up, but
the question was asked horribly.
The exact wording from Lester Holt was who
here would abolish their private health insurance
in favor of a government run plan?
Show of hands to start off with.
He didn't say who would make private insurance
illegal.
He said who would abolish their private health
insurance.
So he's asking who would choose to cancel
their own insurance and instead get government
plan was the way I understood the meaning
of the question.
But clearly some people on the stage interpreted
as who here wants to make private insurance
illegal, which is a terrible moment because
that's a right wing talking point that has
been spreading, right?
I mean it did hurt some of those who didn't
put their hands up, but I wish someone had
just called out the question and said, wait
a second, Leicester.
I want the government involved and I want
private insurance to be irrelevant, but I'm
not talking about making it illegal other
than maybe as a thought experiment that's
a right wing talking point meant to interfere
with serious discussions.
We want people not to need private insurance.
It's not about making it illegal and instead
everybody ended up answering the question
sort of as they understood it and it really
was a mess.
And then lastly, the big losers were John
Delaney.
Bizarre answer after bizarre answer.
Tim Ryan who made a fool out of himself and
Beto O'Rourke betos worst moment when he was
asked, what do you think the top marginal
tax rate should be?
And he broke into incorrect Spanish.
Here is this is my stream and my reaction
to it in real time,
the Sam Democrats want a marginal individual
tax rate of 70% on the very highest earners,
those making more than $10 million a year.
Would you support that?
And if not, what would your top individual
rate be?
This economy has got to work for everyone,
and right now we know that it isn't and it's
going to take all of us coming together to
make sure that it does give us a number of
almost included, got a persona in El Exito,
[inaudible] c get almost a set.
So this deceit almost include [inaudible]
persona in Westerville.
Democrazia a [inaudible].
You're going to do it.
You got a little sit speak Spanish direction.
You got [inaudible] necessary Thomas Escuchar
right now we have a system that favors those
who can pay for access and outcomes.
That's how you explain an economy that is
rigged to corporations and to the very wealthiest,
a $2 trillion tax cut that favored corporations
while they were sitting on record piles of
cash and the very wealthiest in this country
at a time of historic wealth inequality in
new democracy that is required because return
power to the people, no pacs, no gerrymandering,
automatic and same day voter registration
and bringing in more voters and a new voting
rights to get rid of the barriers that are
in place now, right?
That's how we each have a voice in our democracy
and make this up.
Doesn't work for everybody that time, sir.
So he said it's the economy and he said Nuestro
Democrazia so in Spanish, words have gender.
So like if I say professor, if I say professors,
that's a male professor.
If I say put off a soda, that's a female professor.
And when Beto O'Rourke said ace the economy,
he should have said if sta economy I, when
he said Nuestro Democrazia he should've said
[inaudible].
But the problem isn't speaking Spanish per
se.
And it's not that he's spoken correct Spanish,
it was so obviously a concocted and planned
moment.
He's asked for the marginal tax rate and he
speaks Spanish.
And I got emails from people saying, David,
don't tell Hispanic immigrants how they should
feel about what Beto did.
Maybe they liked it.
I'm an immigrant from Argentina, I speak Spanish
at home.
Hearing Robert O'Rourke struggle through incorrect
Spanish to not answer a question, which I
would have loved an answer to.
What should the top marginal tax rate be?
It's just a turn off.
And it felt like such total pandering.
So a bad night for Bedo.
Here's how I scored it, so to speak.
I believe Elizabeth Warren, uh, won this debate,
uh, marginally overbuild.
Deblazio Blasio number two, who Leanne Castro
in third place, Cory booker with a solid showing
in fourth place.
I believe Klobuchar Gabbert and Inslee were
basically tied for fifth place.
Neither of them really factors.
I believe Tim Ryan and Delaney were tied for
eighth place doing damage to themselves.
And lastly, I think Beto O'Rourke was 10 out
of 10 really doing damage to his campaign.
It was very, very bad.
Night
to tonight.
Join me live on Youtube at 8:30 PM eastern
for the live stream and commentary.
Assuming we are not banned from live streaming
on Youtube